[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire reconnaissance spatiale
fichage généralisé géolocalisation à
notre insu et les données sont
conservées on sait où vous étiez à
quelle heure et à qui vous parliez et on
pourra vous le rappeler en temps et en
heure en plus les commissariats s'équipe
de machines permettant d'extraire le
contenu de n'importe quel téléphone
portable
le temps des secrets c'est terminé la
france comme beaucoup d'autres pays est
entré dans l'ère de la surveillance
généralisée dans un système totalitaire
ce serait un progrès considérable mais
dans une démocratie faut-il s'en réjouir
est ce que cela va nous apporter quelque
chose de positif pour en débattre nous
avons invité thibault de montbrial vous
êtes avocat spécialisé dans la défense
des forces de l'ordre police gendarmes
armés mais aussi dans la légitime
défense et la défense des victimes vous
avez fondé et vous êtes le président du
centre de réflexion sur la sécurité
intérieure est l'auteur du livre le
sursaut ou le cas aux éditions plon le
progrès des technologies de surveillance
de masse et la façon dont les états s'en
servent aujourd'hui notamment la france
c'est positif que c'est négatif pour
vous lorsque c'est ni positif ni négatif
c'est un fait c'est à dire que vous avez
un fait technologique et que le fai
technologique ne peut pas être
complètement écartée par la loi la
question c'est comment est ce qu'on s'en
accommode en gardant la balance d
équilibre entre tous les avantages que
l'étape retirer de cette technologie
notamment pour assurer la sécurité de
ses concitoyens qu'elle doit aux
concitoyens et en même temps la liberté
qui est la base de la démocratie
donc il faut s'accommoder de ces
technologies en évitant le pire mais en
en tirant le meilleur et en essayant de
garder cet équilibre car oui c'est bel -
vous êtes entrepreneur vous enseigne à
sciences po la géopolitique appliquée
aux cybers les cultures contemporaines
issues de l'internet et les guerre
informationnelle sur les réseaux sociaux
vous êtes l'auteur de infowar qui est
disponible en livre numérique les
chroniques de l'info war
pour vous les techniques de surveillance
positif ou négatif
c'est effectivement une fatalité ça pose
un problème qui est commun à l'économie
et à la démocratie c'est que si vous
n'avez pas de confiance vous allez
difficilement pouvoir avoir quoi que ce
soit dans l'économie et pareil pour la
démocratie alors la confiance disparaît
donc sur l'économie on pressent tous que
ça va poser des problèmes à maman et sur
la démocratie on voit bien que on est en
train de passer à autre chose
on est en train de réinventer à tâtons
un nouveau système de gouvernance qui va
probante passer par des turbulences mais
qui dit clairement pas l'idée qu'on se
faisait de la démocratie il ya encore
bruno pomart ancien champion de france
de lutte ancien crs puis policiers du
raid pendant 36 ans vous êtes depuis
2014 maire de belflou dans l'aude vous
êtes l'auteur de flics d'élite dans les
cités aux éditions anne carrière
alors on va le voir c'est souvent entre
les mains des maires d'ailleurs
l'intrusion de la nasa tombes de ces
technologies de surveillance pour vous
c'est plutôt positif c'est négatif c'est
plutôt positive partir où la démocratie
la démocratie la partie du mouvement on
l'utilisé avec parcimonie je pourrais
dire suivant les pays à monnaie
nationale et qu'elle recevrait à bon
escient comme le disait mon collègue
tout à l'heure hors plateau
effectivement je pense que la france a
besoin de de beaucoup plus de sécurité
compte tenu qu'on est dans un pays qui
est le plus en plus criminogène de plus
en plus instable
on le voit avec depuis la crise et gilet
jaune en passant par la vague de
terrorisme qu'on a qu'on a accumulées
depuis quelques années donc je crois
qu'il faut utiliser toutes ces
techniques toutes ces technologies pour
répondre tout simplement au grand
banditisme à la voyoucratie à au
terrorisme qui utilise aussi toutes et
tous et moyennes donc je pense que c'est
essentiel je pense même que c'était un
pilier de la démocratie est malade vous
avez été consultante en stratégie
d'entreprise spécialisée dans la
transformation digitale
vous êtes aujourd'hui maître de
conférences à sciences po vous enseigner
l'économie des plateformes
vous intervenez aussi ponctuellement sur
ces sujets à l escp europe écoles dont
vous êtes vous même diplôme est positif
un progrès pour une démocratie comme la
nôtre un progrès je n'irai pas jusque-là
d'innovations technologiques actuels
jusqu'à quel point sa compagne d'un
progrès en tout cas social ça poserait
en question mais ce que ça interroge
fondamentalement ce sont l'ensemble des
atteintes en réalité aux libertés et aux
droits fondamentaux et plus largement
ces nouvelles formes de pouvoir qui
circulent autour de l'économie de la
donne et du big data des algorithmes et
qui montre une intrication permanente
entre privé et public et qui pose la
question de l'état de droit ou du
glissement de l'état de droit vers un
état de la répression de l'ultra
sécurité au retour d'une rhétorique de
la peur et de la méfiance qui peut en
fait réellement poser des questions et
des risques en fait à la démocratie
alors pour lancer ce débat j'aimerais
qu'on réécoute à mes invités de
d'avant-hier benjamin bayart l'un des
fondateurs de la quadrature du net
c'était dans cette émission sur ce
plateau on l'écouté en fait l'histoire
de conservation des données sur lequel
on se base la conservation des données
de connexion qui permet de savoir ce que
qu'ils faisaient quelle adresse ip a été
utilisée oui mais ça donne beaucoup plus
que ça en fait ça donne la
géolocalisation de votre téléphone sadi
où vous êtes camp avec qui est ce que
vous êtes en train de faire et pourquoi
vous y aide
et avec qui vous êtes en train de
discuter à ce moment-là et
reconnaissance faciale et la
conservation des données
c'est un truc de fou et à l'heure
actuelle les obligations de conservation
permettent à l'état de surveiller sa
population le
la grande justice de l'union européenne
a dit que c'était pas bien
elle l'a dit deux fois dans deux arrêts
de grande chambre une manifestement la
france s'en fiche elle souhaite
continuer à espionner sa population la
conservation des 2des sait bien que
c'est pas bien et le fait que la france
ne fasse en dépit de ce que nous dit la
législation européenne
est ce que vous considérez que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement espionne ses
concitoyens je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de fantasmes le gouvernement
n'espionne pas ses concitoyens pour une
raison extrêmement simple c'est que vous
avez une première question qui est celle
de l'accès aux données de leur
conservation et leur stockage
et puis vous avez une donnée que tout le
monde oublie c'est celle de
l'exploitation il n'y a pas d'analysé
c'est à dire que c'est à dire que on a
kout c'est devenu un bateau de le dire
mais je le rappelle les états unis
avaient avant le 11 septembre 2001
technologiquement tous les éléments qui
leur ont permis ensuite de savoir que
s'ils avaient analysé ces événements
plus ces éléments plus tôt en juillet en
août il aura évité les attentats tout y
est à des écoutes téléphoniques et c'est
la seule chose c'est que personne
n'avait rassemblé le poste donc une
chose est de rassembler de la méta
données une autre et de l'analyser alors
on va me dire oui mais aujourd'hui des
ordinateurs sont à ce point puissant que
l'on peut par mots-clés traités etc
mais c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça il faut pas oublier que dans le
renseignement
l'intelligence humaine est un facteur
que con de auquel on peut pas échapper
et vous avez encore régulièrement en
france puisque la question concerne la
france
des loupes et monumentaux avec des gens
par exemple qui sont mis en examen pour
des dossiers dans des dossiers de
terroristes et qui sortent de prison
parce qu'il se remet en liberté ou parce
qu'ils ont une peine qui arrive à
échéance qui normalement devraient être
signalés à la dg ainsi que la sécurité
intérieure parce que le renseignement
per passe le relais à la dgsi donc là
j'ai vraiment très simple c'est pas des
trucs de la mort qui tue c'est vraiment
une fiche est de quelqu'un qui sort de
prison de données d'un service en
seulement un autre et on se rend compte
régulièrement que la dgsi n'est pas au
courant que ces gens sont sortis de
prison ça n'arrive pas à chaque fois
mais ça arrive plus souvent qu'on ne le
croit donc pour des choses aussi simples
on a parfois du mal donc je pense que le
jour où un gouvernement en france sera
en capacité de
avoir exactement en se posant la
question de savoir tiens vous tient ce
monsieur il a dit du mal de moi à la
télé la semaine dernière où était-il
exactement ces trois des personnels qui
a vu avant les amendes et si vous avez
absolument du domaine du fantasme
si jamais si jamais un gouvernement
décidé de mettre les moyens pour être
capables de faire ce genre de choses
d'abord ça se saurait parce que des gens
dans la chaîne mise en place mon frère
parlerait est très choqué il n'y a pas
100 % que fasciste chez les
fonctionnaires qui s'occupe de ces
sujets premièrement et deuxièmement ça
occuperait à ce point les gens chargés
de la sécurité que très vite il ne
pourrait pas s'occuper du reste donc est
ce que le risque théorique existe sans
doute que oui et je vais pas les
capacités techniques pour rentrer dans
le détail mais pour parler vraiment au
quotidien de ces sujets avec les gens
qui s'occupent de ces questions et en
particulier qui s'occupe de la question
de l'analyse qui est le sujet principal
je vous le dis très simplement sané en
pratique pas possible même aux états
unis qui sont beaucoup plus avancés que
nous sur ces questions les américains ne
sont pas en capacité de faire ça et
pourtant on dit que la haine essais et
peut être acceptée à peu à peu près
n'importe quel propos sur la planète
donc je pense que cette attente
réponse de fabrice epelboin alors deux
choses d'une part ya la capter de
collecte elle a capté de collecte sans
aller jusqu'aux kpc d'années ça la
france fait partie des grands champions
de la surveillance vous renvoie à
l'investigation été publiée dans
mediapart sur un ol qui est le système
de collecte qui vise citoyens français
pas le territoire extérieur mais
vraiment le territoire français bio elle
ensuite vous avez tout à fait raison il
ya la capacité à faire sens de tout ça
et là là dessus la france a toujours été
ma peine on a commencé avec des systèmes
comme eagle de amicis bull qui était
absolument incapable de faire sens de
grand chose sur le territoire français
qui était tout juste suffisant pour
kadhafi et on en est arrivé vers la fin
du quinquennat de françois hollande à
acquérir des technologies américaines
palantir qui servent à ça et qui ont
fait largement leurs preuves et qui sont
utilisés par toutes les agences de
renseignement américaines
c'était à l'époque où on imaginait que
hillary clinton allait être élu dans sur
un plateau d'argent
et ensuite on s'est aperçu que palantir
c'était la société peter style qui était
le monsieur numérique de donald trump et
et proche de facebook les mêmes assez
proche de caméras et 10 k donc on s'est
aperçu qu'on a fait une très grosse
erreur stratégique etc au passage on
avait perdu une partie de souveraineté
de notre renseignement mais on masse et
les renseignements que nous collectons
avec cette technologie il la collecte
aussi par la même occasion
est-ce qu'on se souvient pendant des
semaines entières ça ne fallait pas
aussi simple que ça mais forcément c'est
loin d'être possiblement hermétique mais
c'est pas aussi basiques que ça mais
malgré tout on a des capacités de
surveillance qui sont spectaculaires
mais qui dépendent totalement des états
unis en termes d'analysé pas de récolte
est ce qu'on les utilise à bon escient
de toute évidence non mais on a tout à
fait laisser ses capacités et s'il
s'agit de savoir très précisément quel
était votre emploi du temps hier à 12h30
ya aucun souci absolument aucun souci
c'est d'une simplicité biblique ces
logiciels sont faits pour ça alors après
il n'y a pas un personnel pléthorique
derrière ces logiciels de façon à
surveiller toute la population ça ça
sera à l'occasion d'une prochaine
évolution ou d'une cible est simplement
si demain les enquêtes sur moi et on le
saura jamais sur vous on enquête et il y
a aucun souci mais sur le citoyen
ordinaire pour une affaire vraiment très
ordinaire non on n'en est pas là on en
est loin et ça sera certainement pas
dans ce quinquennat là qu'on passera ce
niveau là par contre technologiquement
parlant on est prêt depuis quinquennat
hollande oui il ya des commissions de
contrôle qui sont très strictes je
discutais cet après-midi un couvent un
peu lié ses draps avec un copain qui est
qui à la dgsi à toulouse qui
m'expliquait que lorsqu'ils veulent
lancer des procédures des coups on
l'entend concret pas dans la
surveillance du du français lambda que
nous sommes évidemment c'est les gens
qui sont recherchées ciblés par les
services de police
je reste sur ce domaine là qui le disait
lui-même jeudi mais vous pouvez faire
disons qu'on voulait mais me dit mais tu
es fou c'est fini ça lezons d'avant il
appelait ça des perquis mexicaine c'est
à dire en fait on faisait un petit peu
ce qu'on voulait et c'est avoir du temps
de pasqua et de tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer
maintenant c'est fini donc il ya quand
même un contrôle interne qui est très
stricte dans le domaine policier soit
clair assure il souhaite sur des
éléments bien ciblés mais je crois qu'en
même temps on a besoin de cette
technologie au plus haut niveau
parce que le terrorisme pour en revenir
à ce sujet qui est quand même très
important je pense dans notre société
a besoin de fait tout moment les
services de renseignement ont besoin
d'information de plus en plus précises
pour pouvoir traiter ces problématiques
de terrorisme parce que ces gens-là
sincère aussi de tous ces moyens là donc
je pense que nous si on si on n'est pas
comment dire à l'écouté de tout ce qui
se passe sur ces éléments ciblés et
croyez moi qui sont nombreux et si les
services de police comme les rt services
de renseignement territoriaux au même
titre que la dg et s'ils n'avaient pas
ces possibilités d'écouté sur la sphère
du terrorisme qui qui qui plombe notre
notre pays et l'europe entière et le
monde mais le problème est plus sûr les
journalistes que son généraliste on est
d'accord et sur le citoyen lambda sur
les théories en passant comment
contrôler tous les journalistes et les
gaffes idylle est quelque chose de sûre
sur facebook franchement très plaisant
benoît marc vous savez bien et c'est je
crois un ministre de l'intérieur qui
l'avait dit toutes les lois d'exception
qu'on vote mais pour contre le
terrorisme par exemple on sait que ce
sera appliqué ensuite à d'autres que
pour ceux pour qu'elle soit aujourd'hui
ça a toujours été comme ça c'est à dire
que ça serait les lloris en fait ça sert
contre les écologistes contre l'ultra
gauche contre l'aigle ultra droite
contre mais c'est toujours que les
terroristes qu'on l'a fait mais c'est
jamais pour eux contenaient mais le sou
le renseignement
existe depuis le champion du monde a été
mi terrain et ses équipes ah bon oui
mais de façon beaucoup pouvait remarquer
que maintenant parce qu'on n'avait pas
tous ses moyens technologiques mais
services it et pas plus beau mais je
vote oui de façon beaucoup plus
prosaïque indépendamment et pour
dépasser un peu la question des
renseignements et de la police récemment
on a insisté quand même à la validation
d'un fichier d'un méga fichier qui
s'appelle le fichier t es et qui fiche
puisque c'est la question sous jacente
c'est le fichage de la population
française donc c'est un fichier qui va
ficher et qui fiche déjà 65 millions 67
millions de français et notamment qui
consolide l'ensemble des données
biométriques donc tout à l'heure on fera
certainement le lien avec les sujets de
reconnaissance faciale in salon on avait
le fichier tâche qui lui ressent c'est
plutôt toutes les personnes qui étaient
mises en garde à vue de cet art a
aujourd'hui on a élargi le spectre et au
delà de la question du journaliste du
policier du terroriste en réalité c'est
l'ensemble de la population qui est
fiché dans ce dossier dans ce fichier
pour des raisons officielles
d'authentification d'identification de
simplification administrative et ses
terrains or ça pose une question d'abord
de sécurité parce que quand on consolide
l'ensemble de données aussi sensible que
votre photo votre visage vos empreintes
digitales votre filiation votre
ascendance votre descendance votre
adresse etc
il ya un risque accru de hacking parce
qu'en fait ça devient une cible
prioritaire d'une part et d'autre part
ça facilite derrière ça devait une base
de comparaison pour des technologie
intrusive de type reconnaissance faciale
est donc là on ne parle plus de quelques
populations ciblées critiques
journalistes se dotèrent orist et ses
terrains mais on parle de l'ensemble de
la population
et aujourd'hui c'est un fichage qui a
déjà été validé par le conseil d'état
j'étais d'accord
thibault de montbrial non mais je pense
que fin on peut pas aller contre le fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des capacités qui
permettent de mettre dans un même
fichier votre nom votre adresse votre
tête et c'est top pour ce qu'affirme un
couac en maille comment est-ce que
comment est ce qu'on justifie on aurait
pu décentralisée
comment est-ce qu'on commence quand
justifiera auprès de la population
alors lors de si jamais demain il se
passe un événement grave que les
services de police ont perdu ont perdu
un certain nombre d'heures parce qu'il a
fallu etc
et croyez moi des exemples existent
depuis très longtemps ça n'a pas empêché
l'ensemble des attentats qu'on lâche
alors ça n'empêche pas une règle
d'airain non mais attendez j'ai juste
une parenthèse mais que le principe d'un
attentat éviter c'est qu'on en entend
parler donc alors oui je suis aussi
lucide sur le fait que ça peut être une
argumentation politique qui consiste non
seulement je fais des raisonnements
cours mais fou comme que je suis s'est
faite le
aujourd'hui le fait que les données de
base concernant quelqu'un soient
facilement accessibles à
l'administration
c'est quelque chose qui enfin quand vous
faites votre passeport toutes ces
données elles y sont quand vous passez
au système paraphes à roissy 11,5 et
helsana certaines valeurs sur la
question mais vous avez un nom a déjà
les reconnaissances raciale ça peut être
jamais on va le dire après la
reconnaissance spatiale je pense que je
voudrais juste répondre avant qu'on
arrive à la reconnaissance faciale
aujourd'hui la question des fichiers
c'est une question de conservation une
question d'accès et là où vous avez tout
à fait raison
et là je vous rejoins tout à fait c'est
que met tout le monde en est conscient
c'est que plus on avance dans une
technologie qui permet de rassembler des
éléments qui pourront être utiles
notamment en matière de sécurité etc
plus on s'expose à ce que cette
technologie soit dévoyé donc ça c'est un
fait
c'est ça c'est la question entre de la
bataille entre l'épée et le bouclier
pour tous donc ça nous amène à la
sécurité informatique
il ya juste un deuxième point que
j'aimerais soulever pour faire un salon
n'est pas aussi en série dont je
voudrais c'est arrivé c'est aussi que l'
on vous parlait de d'une surveillance ou
d'une malhonnêteté on va dire d'état
mais vous avez aussi oui mais qui reste
un fichage data qui entraînerait une
malhonnêteté éventuelle de l'état mais
ce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est que si on
oublie l'état tous les gens qui sont
parce que moi des débats sur sécurité
liberté j'en ai depuis 2014 et je suis
le seul avocat à être du côté de ceux
qui sont plutôt sur le répressif
donc j'ai un peu l'habitude et je
réponds toujours la même chose de 2,3 de
2,3 ce qui marche
je vous en propose à tous les gens pas
vous personnellement on se connaît pas
et je me permettrai pas mais tous les
gens qui sont dans cette logique de
s'inquiéter comme vous etc
c'est le premier à raconter leur vie et
à tout mettre sur fès et les engager le
débat avec vous je sais l'occurrence je
pense que vous ne le fait ça mais si on
met mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui le
font et vous avez aussi je le pose là et
on en parlera peut-être le fait que des
sociétés privées qui sont plus
puissantes que certains états ont
également accès à ces éléments vous
parliez d'économie ça pose aussi un
problème sur les interrogations de la
maintenance voilà donc on n'est pas
simplement sur la parra yona la paranoïa
pardon de l'espionnage d'état pour
savoir que tel le méchant journalistes
pensent du président sharif est belle
bain juste un petit malentendu selon
l'asnav parler c'est là le danger en
termes de cybersécurité qui a rassemblé
dans un seul fichier unique tout ça il
ya aucun problème pour mettre ça dans 25
fichiers éparses
justement parlant tiercé revenir tout ça
et faire sens de tout ça 6 la grosse
différence que vous allez avoir c'est
que entre un fichier qui sera attaqué
inévitablement ça a été le cas de l'inde
ça a été cadre des états unis tous ces
fichiers là sont systématiquement
attaqués si vous aviez 25 péchés ce
serait beaucoup plus résilient donc il
ya un problème de d'appréhension de la
chose technique par le législateur c'est
pas nouveau mais là il ya eu un choix
technique fait par le législateur qui
pose un énorme problème de sécurité
alors qu'il avait d'autres alternatives
qui n'aurait pas posé les mêmes
problèmes de sécurité qui aurait conduit
exactement mc rae service à la police un
c'est pas du tout un problème de quand
il s'agit de prendre 25 fichiers de
faire de les réunir à un moment donné
pour avoir toutes les informations sur
un individu c'est très simple à faire
et qui plus est les technologies
d'analysé qu'on a acquis auprès des
américains justement excelle à faire ça
et là il ya vraiment eu un choix
technique fait par l'illustrateur en
dépit du bon sens d'un point de vue
sécurité on y travaille à peine un mois
il ya peu de temps chez europol et
eurojust donc à l'europe où il travaille
alors il ya tout un tas d'acronymes je
vous passe les détails parce qu'il ya un
nombre de fichiers qu'on est en train de
mettre en parallèle et la liaision pour
pouvoir travailler plus sur le
terrorisme trois bombes manière tous les
états et tout le monde y travaille et
l'europe en priorité pour l'état
est-ce arrivé pas vraiment de madame
michu des 2 67 millions de citoyens
français qui vont voir leurs données
mais pirates et oui mais diablement moi
je pense que vous êtes un peu dans nos
fantasmes excusez moi de vous dire si
c'est ça la vie on n'est pas donné mais
c'est en chine on n'est pas notre chance
en chine en mai on a marre il faut être
logique je pense que ce travail qui est
fait si vous paraît évidemment si vous
fait peur en cybersécurité il est moins
cher à risque ben ouais mais mettez-vous
du côté des policiers des gens qui
travaillent tous les jours
alors c'est la confédération s'est dit
justement mettons-nous du côté des
policiers qui dans au moins 500
commissariat où les îles ont bientôt
équipée d'une machine permettant
d'extraire directement les données des
téléphones portables des gardés à vue
avant il fallait envoyer le téléphone
portable au labo et puis parfois le labo
n'arrivait pas à ouvrir le téléphone
portable qui était trop bien protégées
on avait eu une affaire assez
intéressante avec apple qui avait refusé
de donner le code à là c'était la cia je
me souviens plus mais qui est devenu de
l'exiger là bas normalement d'après ce
que dit cette technologie il n'y a pas
un seul téléphone qui pourra résister
alors quand on sait selon cheikh news la
rubrique de libération que cette société
qui fabrique et commercialise ses
machines a elle même été victime d'un
piratage informatique et que le pirate a
récolté quoi forcément des données
collectées par la police ce qui veut
dire que s'était donné au téléphone
portable qu'on inspire on les accuse pas
seulement pour la police mais aussi pour
la société qui fabrique les machines
est ce que c'est un progrès pour la
démocratie c'est un peu le chien qui se
mord la queue parce que vous aurez
toujours des la tentation d'utiliser mes
même l'obligation d'utiliser les
nouvelles technologies ster que et pays
le bouclier
vous avez aujourd'hui des téléphones
dans lequel il ya la vie des gens donc
la vie des délinquants
donc le délinquant qui se fait choper
par exemple prenez les applications
comme télégramme ou one that qui sont
très difficiles à casser comment est-ce
que les gens se font à voir avec les
messages sur leur messagerie c'est pas
parce qu'elles sont choqués par
l'extérieur c'est parce qu'ils ne
fassent pas leur message jean jacques
fourès donc s'élancer knox donc c'est
exactement ça serait pareil au niveau de
la justice
donc vous êtes donc donc d'où l'intérêt
pour pour la justice via la police de se
saisir des terminaux bon donc à partir
du moment où il ya une technologie qu'il
permet la technologie est appliquée ça
permet de gagner du temps et
d'efficacité dans les enquêtes et si
dedans y'a rien incriminant les gens
seront remis en liberté parce que après
c'est la chaîne pénale qui fonctionne
bien ou mal mais selon des principes
démocratiques bien jean vient la
question technologique vous à vous me
dites oui mais alors du coup on peut à
quai le système qui met le hacking et le
fait d'aller chercher de faire une
intrusion pour aller chercher ce qui
attendait dans des dossiers dans des
fichiers ça a toujours été le cas
moi je vous dis que je suis moins
inquiet de ça même si je ne nie pas du
tout je suis extrêmement conscient des
risques que ça peut générer
je suis moins inquiet que ça que d'un
hacking qui viendraient privés
d'électricité une grande ville pendant
trois jours sachant qu'on sait puisque
des études qui sont fait que c'est une
ville n'a plus d'électricité pendant
trois jours le troisième jour c'est les
émeutes parce qu'il ya plus à manger
voilà moi je suis plus inquiet par ça
alors vous allez me dire on va y aller
vers un profil de rhinau parce que c'est
pas les mêmes genres mais je sais je
sais mais je montre juste presque par
l'absurde que la question de la
vulnérabilité de nos sociétés et c'est
la question presque philosophique que
vous nous posez ce soir la question de
la vulnérabilité de nos sociétés aux
technologies auxquelles elles s'offrent
de plus en plus c'est une question qui
bien au-delà de l'intimité des gens est
une question vitale au sens propre
donc c'est un sujet vital au sens propre
il ya le sujet dont vous nous parler qui
est un sujet d'inquiétude réel mais bien
au delà
la cyber sécurité est un sujet vital
alors je ne suis pas du tout d'accord
avec saint pardon mais est vraiment sur
le fond c'est-à-dire que quand on va à
quai
le fera un fichier de ski dont contient
votre photo votre empreinte digitale et
qu'on fait en fait en votre nom avec
votre visage et votre empreinte qui sont
donc votre identité inaltérable ce n'est
pas un password que vous pouvez changer
vous pourrez jamais changé de visage ou
d'empreintes digitales et qu'on vous
fera faire en votre nom
en votre visage une activité criminelle
quelconque en fait on change de société
on passe de la présente dans l'innocence
à la présomption de culpabilité et
comment allez vous prouvez votre
innocuité enfin pardon j'ai pas dû être
juste une droite le risque est énorme et
ce n'est pas démocratique c'est un fait
de société jeux quelle société on je
suis comme je suis j'ai pas dit que le
risque n'était pas énorme
jeudi que le risque est énorme pour tout
ce qui concerne la cybersécurité mais ce
que vous dites est vrai mais du coup je
répondrai que c'est à dire qu'elle a
évidemment si on a qu'une ville
l'énergie émeutes mais en réalité nos
données biométriques en fait c'est
vraiment ce qui définit de façon intime
une identité une personnalité un
individu donc hors ca ca câble au jeu
après un dialogue entre nous mais juste
un mot vous avez raison mais allons plus
loin l'image les technologies
aujourd'hui vidéo serait remettre nommé
permettent de créer un film où vous
allez puisque vous parlez de moi
j'aurais sur moi même pour ne mettre
personne mal à l'aise je peux le mettre
en scène avec leur une situation fictive
où je vais faire ou dire des choses que
je n'aurais jamais fait ou dit et si je
suis un dirigeant politique le temps que
l'on démonte là que l'on démontre la
fausseté du film qui vient d'être
chercheur
ça peut déclencher une guerre donc vous
avez raison mais ces départs est
uniquement pour les données personnelles
ce qu'on est en train de dire et là je
pense qu'on a vus dénier là pour le coup
une unanimité c'est que il ya une
préoccupation vital qui découlent de ces
nouvelles technologies
je propose de faire une pause on se
retrouve juste après et on poursuit ce
débat notamment sur la révolution qui va
occasionner la reconnaissance faciale
[Musique]
haïm et des pays africains à l'euro
c'est une évidence bêtise la face à
maintenir des français parce que selon
le crr instruments qui sont la
protection de ses intérêts économiques
en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui était
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question de la date fixe
avait dit non mais c'est est-ce que
c'est big money même prochain le sujet
aujourd'hui en afrique c'est pas d'avoir
une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de tirer entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
mais
je trouve votre sentiment sur les
mouvements concernant la manifestation
contre la retraite quand il ya autant de
travail qui a autant de chômeurs autant
de gens qui sont dans la logique comme
on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à repenser
le travail c'est vraiment une question
philosophique pour moi je défends les
gilet jaune qui sont pour moi les sous
prolétaires je défends également ces
gens là qui pour le coup ce sont les
prolétaires mais qui sont organisés pour
parce que c'est toujours les mêmes qui
payent les pots plus modestes et c est
pourquoi ce sont toujours les mêmes qui
échappent soit à l'impôt soit aux
ponctions d'autres choses qui font que
s'il y avait vraiment un désir d'équité
les français seraient probablement plus
à même de devenir qu'il consente à ce
traitement est ce que vous avez compris
quelle était la revendication au moment
des gilets jaunes tout au départ ce sont
juste des gens qui disent si vous
augmentez le prix du carburant nous on
va pas pouvoir des gens disaient mais
moi je suis chez mes parents parce que
je ne peux pas me payer un loyer alors
que je travaille donc dès le départ
c'était une revendication de dignité
mais vous avez dit on n'a pas écouté ces
gens là comment vouliez vous les écoutez
puisque personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre y en un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale
[Musique]
nous prenons notre débat sur les
technologies de surveillance avec
thibault de montbrial avec fabrice
epelboin bruno pomart et asma mala alors
le gros morceau on l'a dit c'est la
reconnaissance faciale qui arrive alors
en france pour l'instant on a fait des
expérimentations avec connaissance qu'à
nice non le cas tu riddick est en place
depuis grosso modo la loppsi 2 donc ça
fait six ans à peu près qu'il ya des
expérimentations un peu dans tous les
sens finalement que celle de nice au
moment du carnaval
marcel etienne il ya énormément
d'expérimentation depuis six ans
notamment là il ya de la reconnaissance
faciale qui a été appliquée aux
manifestations mais enfin ces secteurs
noté dans tous les sens ça ça donne pas
nécessairement des résultats très
intéressants de ce sont les comiques
mais c'est vraiment pléthore
d'expérimentation depuis six ans
maintenant alors qu'il veut de mont
royal
c'est un progrès tout dépend ce qu'on en
fait je vais vous faire toujours les
mêmes réponses
vous avez par exemple mais à la question
de la conservation de l'accès
aujourd'hui par exemple quand vous
rentrez en france
en rentrant de l'étranger à roissy et
vous utilisez le système paraphes pour
pas faire la queue ou plus ou moins
faire la grimace par les douanes vous
avez de la reconnaissance faciale
simplement n'est pas enregistrée c'est à
dire que le leur on ne garde pas la
photo alors pourquoi la salle justifie
totalement c'est que sinon on pourrait
voyager que le passeport d'un hôte voilà
jusqu'à maintenant le douanier identifie
que c'est le même qui éclaire un
passeport etc et sur le batailleur mais
ce cas il faut quelque chose vous voyez
vous prenez déjà partie parce que vous
dites là ça se justifie totalement même
avoir en débatte donc où est le seuil de
la aux astuces justifie absolument pas
en réalité sur la question de la
reconnaissance sociale tels que j'ai
compris que vous la poser c'est la
question de pouvoir identifier dans une
foule quelqu'un canapé ultérieurement
reconstruire aux mêmes questions que se
posent les chinois alors certes de la
reconnaissance faciale pour empêcher les
hongkongais de manifester mais on se dit
que demain on pourrait faire exactement
la même chose le gouvernement français
quel qu'il soit a autant intérêt que le
gouvernement chinois est ce qu'il n'y
ait pas de manifester mais cédé au club
aux moyens de dissuader les gens de
manifester a parlé lbd40 mais si c'est
un élément spécial mais 6 a touché des
éléments perturbateurs sont des manifs
on parle du mouvement black book
évidemment ils sont masqués mais
ça peut permettre de suivre
effectivement un gars qui a commis un
délit grave moi personnellement ça ne me
dérange pas et moi comme un film ça ne
me dérange pas cependant les mains
gouvernement d'autres direct si ça
dissuade les gens dans leur totalité de
manifester ça ne me dérange pas
nombreuses causes pour non sans que je
sois pas les gens des manifs pendant les
manifestations contre la loi de travail
on avait assigné à résidence était
militant écolo demain on les identifiera
par reconnaissance spatiale et
éventuellement on les poursuivre en
justice
ils montrent leur nez dans mes cc je
vous rejoins tout à fait là dessus il ya
eu un côté inéluctable de cette
technologie qui font que c'est
absolument unique table on n'y échappera
pas de là l'utilisation la plus évidente
c'est le tout ce qui couvre feu qui
aujourd'hui quelque chose de
relativement théorique et pas forcément
évident à mettre en oeuvre pour les
forces de police mais qui demain sera
d'une simplicité absolue
nora l'identié tout le monde des
policiers de tout le monde il suffira
d'y identifier quelqu'un en dehors de
son lieu d'assignation pour lui envoyer
une amende ou le gign si vraiment c'est
quelqu'un de très sympa très dangereux
mais on aura cette possibilité de
réaliser vraiment un des murs sans la
moindre gramme de béton et ça ça va
arriver très très vite
ça vous a pas échappé quand même qu'on
vit dans une société moi je suis
d'accord avec vous on vit dans une
société de plus en plus criminogènes où
il ya de plus en plus de risques
moi je vous assurer que tous les jours
je suis souvent sur les plateaux télé à
défendre la maison police tous les jours
les copains me disent les compagnies
d'intervention tout ce que vous pouvez
imaginer pas seulement les gendarmes
mobiles et les crs qui sont sur le
terrain à faire du métier noland que ça
devient de plus en plus compliquée a
déjà plus que je n'ai pas d'espoir
démocratique si notre question bête oui
je te propose déjà dans les airs hier
non mais c'est vraiment vraiment des
outils sont utiles pour ne pas voir où
il peut dire aussi qu'il ya moins de
crimes aujourd'hui qu'il ya trente ans
enfin benoît qu'il ya 50 ans non mais ça
c'est la première fois depuis 2002 s'il
y en a moins qu'avant alors c'est vrai
qu'on est plus policé
non mais ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a moins de tolérance au crime à la
violence parce qu'il y en a - justement
et que donc on veut pas dire qu'on est
de plus en plus violents au contraire on
a été de moins en moins ça remonte à
tout y est pour que je passais la
société elle-même a interpellé colton
moi je travaille beaucoup dans
l'associatif et des jeunes
j'ai 25 ans d'associatifs j'ai vu la
jeunesse évoluer les jeunes de 15 16 ans
qui sont beaucoup plus violents
maintenant c'est à dire que je les
encadre et mes équipes c'était plus que
je
il ya quinze ans en arrière donc voilà
on a vraiment une société qui devient
compliqué et je pense que le rempart
c'est celui qui sait le flic et qui est
devant avec l'assistante sociale et qui
en prend plein la gueule et c'est pour
ça qu'en même temps la réponse du
gouvernement à tord ou à raison mais moi
je pense à raison en étant contrôlés
évidemment de ces systèmes
on est obligé de d'aider les policiers
dans avec toutes les technologies toutes
les nouvelles technologies au même titre
que les élus d'ailleurs ce que les élus
nous aussi on a des problèmes à régler
au jour le jour des civilités tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer
pour l'instant les caméras de
surveillance entre guillemets n'ont pas
été les meilleurs alliés des policiers
on a vu ça et surtout permis de
documenter les violences policières je
suppose que ça permet de résoudre des
affaires
oui bien sûr mais ça permet surtout de
rentabiliser des infrastructures de
vidéosurveillance qui ont coûté très
cher et on se fait très très peu
efficaces et aujourd'hui pas dire son
nom est aujourd'hui à peu de ma peau
pour des coûts relativement raisonnable
on incorpore aimons encore des logiciels
dits acp de reconnaissance faciale qui
tout d'un coup rentabilise des
infrastructures existantes et qu'on
n'arrivait pas à amortir aussi donc mais
aussi une toute une économie une gestion
des coûts par par les administrations et
par les municipalités sur commence quand
finalement va rentabiliser des
infrastructures de vidéosurveillance qui
n'était pas intelligent
les miss france affichent leur
rentabilité s'est on sent qu'ici pas du
tout mais c'est que ça a été un argument
fort et c'est aussi un ami c'est un
argument très fort mais par les arts par
les uns oui c'est vrai mais par les
armes
parlez-en aux gens qui seront qui se
baladent de jouer jour etc vous diront
pas sa part publier dans le journal et
camille rajotte gens qui me demandent un
mot à mot parce que peut-être peu faut
être clair pour les téléspectateurs
la vidéosurveillance aujourd'hui très
franchement il n'empêche rien n'empêche
pas les crimes mais paris n'en sais rien
n'y fait mais alors il ya des gens que
ça dit soit vous avez dit mais surtout
mais surtout elle permet une élucidation
d'un certain les affaires qui avant
n'était pas assez je vous donne un
exemple parmi des dizaines
vous avez un type qui a commis lors des
samedis de gilet jaune les plus violents
une agression particulièrement violente
contre un policier et il a été identifié
cas mais il
la préfecture de police la traque et
caméras par caméra et on a fini par y
dans deux par les identifier parce que
il a fait trois kilomètres à pied en par
les petites rues etc
il est remonté sur son scooter et on l'a
retrouvé caméra par caméra avec un
travail de bénédictin humain c'est eux
qui a permis de prendre la place de son
succès exactement l'exemple que vous
preniez tout à l'heure difficile
d'analyser les données avant mais quand
ça va dans le cas de l'attentât à nice
du 14 juillet personne ne voit rien dans
les caméras de surveillance est clair on
voit pas qui rappelle un truc je suis en
revanche après on veut remonter
on peut suivre la personne donc là c'est
ce qui est arrivé pour les attentats à
paris en janvier 2015 on a pu retrouver
un sur deux donc en ce sens on peut pas
dire que la vidéosurveillance ne sert à
rien mais c'est vrai qu'elle n'appelle à
la sof ce qu'elles disent mais je
parlais de rentabilisation du alors la
cnav et inondé les rues de vidéo serait
question que je voulais vous poser
baumard on le disait c'est souvent par
les maires ce sont les maires qui ont
les clés responsabilités vous le savez
vous qui est maire d'un petit village
sans vote habito pourquoi pensez-vous
que la vidéosurveillance a peut être
intéressante pour un piège comme vous je
croyais que c'était pour les grandes
villes on peut le comprendre quand on
voit cette image là on se dit bon bah
une petite caméra ça rassure puis ça
permet d'élucider rétrospectivement s
attend le cas mais un village de 120
habitants
je vais parler vraiment casquette de
maire et de flics donc à aussi donc
c'est évidemment automatiquement je suis
comme vous me dire complètement
favorable à ce dispositif
on est sollicité on a été sollicité par
une société rongée par le non en tête et
qui est venue de démarcher pour dire
tiens voilà il ya beaucoup d'incivilités
les problématiques de dépôt d'ordures
des trucs bas qui sont complètement
banane effectivement est ce que ça vous
intéresserait d'avoir des caméras
je tiens pourquoi pas et comment vous
voyez le dispositif il est pas très
grande envie d'argent effectivement une
entrée et une sortie
bon effectivement la logique voudrait
dire une caméra l'entrée de caméra sur
tous les profils
on en parle plus on sait ce qu'ils rose
qui vient pourquoi tout simplement de se
rassurer la population parce que je les
dis en réunion municipale
on m'a dit tu as réussi une bonne idée
pourtant on n'est pas touché par le
crime tout ce qu'on peut imaginer
mais on est on est touché par des
problématiques d'incivilités qui
emmerdent mais habitant évidemment où
les déchets convenait d'échelle partout
rôle exact où prévalent dans ces cas là
ça fait plutôt plaisir aux mêmes qui
dénoncent les quais les caméras de
surveillance il dit quand ça permet de
trouver ça c'est très français
et pour vous dire je vais plus loin d'un
mandat morisod demain c'est que je vous
disais je suis dans l'aude et à une
heure de chez moi ça m'a fait penser à
ça mais c'est peut-être parce que je
suis complètement dans ce truc dans ce
trip une heure de chez moi ils artibat
l'imam blanc qui a pris en même de mes
rares chiens etc etc je me dis waouh si
c'était dans mon village d'autres comme
ça je connais tout le monde évidemment
mais est ce que ça aurait pas permis je
réfléchis comme ça à haute voix est ce
que ça aurait pas permis d'éviter ça ou
de pouvoir suivre effectivement ces gens
là alors artiga qui n'a pas dans la
france entière dans les villages qui
avait accueilli des terroristes en herbe
mais pour autant voilà ça m'a fait
réfléchir indien jioi si artigas a
peut-être que services de renseignements
auraient pu avoir des informations
je précise juste un tout petit mot pour
rebondir sur un mot vous avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est que vous avez dit ça
déplace aussi la criminalité mais moi je
suis désolé quand vous êtes responsable
parce que vous avez un mandat de deux
d'une d'une ville ou d'un village ville
ou d'un village peu importe les gens
vous demandent notamment de la sécurité
si parce que vous faites une
installation avec le voisin n'en fais
pas ça déplace la criminalité sur la
commune du voisin vous comme maire de
votre commune
c'est pas notre problème je mets comme
président de l'aja mais que je n'en
mettrais l'exemple est le meilleur
exemple que je vais vous donner c'est
que vous avez un certain nombre
d'endroits où les gens votent
l'installation de caméras factices
c'est à dire que la simple la caméra à
une simple vertu de dissuasion ça c'est
quand même et ça c'est quand même c'est
quand même peu ça permet ça permet de
2,2 la dissuasion peut pas le quantifier
parce que ce qui n'arrive pas il est
difficile de le mesurer
mais c'est extraordinaire parce qu'en
fait le point que vous soulevez
finalement en filigrane et de façon
implicite c'est la question du choix de
société là on parle de carrément
l'associé de contrôle de deux le c'est à
dire une on est en train de façonner de
nouvelles normes d'autocensure en
réalité on va mettre des caméras
factices ou des caméras réellement
opérationnels intégrant de lia et en été
on va créer de nouveaux comportements
ça c'est d'une part et d'autre part la
question que vous posez vous aussi c'est
la quête finalement c'est une forme de
glissement du contrat social initial
c'est-à-dire kiné initialement c'était
fini basiquement l'état de droit c'était
liberté contre sécurité l'ont finalement
ça devient
berthet contre sécurité contre vie
privée et la question non pas du tout
assez depuis le début de ce débat c'est
la question des atteintes aux droits
fondamentaux vie privée le droit de
manifester l'opinion le droit de 2,2 de
liberté de pensée et c est ça aurait été
quand on kadri et quand on surveille
l'ensemble pour un risque éventuel pour
en attraper un où quelques-uns c'est un
vrai choix de société qui aujourd'hui ne
fait l'objet d'aucun réel débat non pas
publics mais démocratique du débat
public
poussé par le gouvernement il y en a
pléthore est en réalité ça se réduit
comme peau de chagrin à quelques
conseils d'éthique à droite à gauche qui
écrivent au dd des pages et des rapports
entier de recommandations assez
théorique et creuse la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la population les
français la société civile n'est pas
suffisamment formés ne comprend pas
suffisamment finalement les enjeux n'ont
pas technologique mais politiques et
sociaux de ce que ça suppose et la
reconnaissance faciale typiquement c'est
pas une technologie en réalité c'est une
idéologie
quand on parle de quel est le contrat
social quels sont les nouveaux contours
de l'état de droit est ce qu on sait ce
qu'on est capable finalement de renoncer
à notre vie privée pour des questions
sécuritaires qui en réalité aussi infuse
dans une ambiance dans une rhétorique
politique générale depuis quelques
années de la peur de l'app store de la
répression de la méfiance est donc en
réalité c'est aussi tout à l'heure on
disait c'est un peu un cercle vicieux où
finalement on alimente la population les
chaînes d'info finalement sont en train
se projette les mêmes faits divers en
permanence dites vous que tu étais
encore été ont créé un climat de
méfiance de distance ambitieux dont je
suis fier de notre image et son c'est
absolument lié
je pourrais vous dire pourquoi essayer
tout à l'heure on parlait de domotique
et je vais faire le dire tout de suite
et je finirai là dessus la domotique et
on parle et finalement de l'ensemble des
usages et plus largement des usages
commerciaux et 10 finalement la
reconnaissance faciale pour desvarieux
son iphone ou pour gagner de
l'expérience usagers ou de la fluidité
au portique d'aéroport ben pourquoi pas
mais quand il sa vie
de l' usage sécuritaire policiers là ça
peut poser un peu plus de questions et
notamment démocratique la réalité c'est
qu'en fait les deux sujets sont
parfaitement liés et qu'en réalité on
est en train de développer une
accoutumance aux usages une expérience
usagers qui finalement endort et
anesthésie l'esprit critique et on
commence par du facebook par l'iphone
par le portique par les deux lycées bon
ça a été retoqué par la crise mais
parler de lisser au le carnaval de nice
tout toujours des prétextes soit de
fluidité soit de sécurité et henry était
petit à petit on glisse vers des usages
policiers vers des usages sécuritaire
aujourd'hui relativement relativement
réglementée par un état de droit et par
la loi demain encadrement ni la
tentative manquée de changement de
régime on dit toujours c'est la
prochaine ça va être encore macron le
pen d'accord non en cas de régime ou de
changement de régime
on a en réalité installer l'ensemble des
briques d'une réelle société de
surveillance entre les bases de
comparaison les fichiers de comparaison
le ts on en a parlé entre en fait les
caméras de vidéosurveillance qui sont
déjà installés et condom on incorpore
déjà finalement les codes les logiciels
de reconnaissance faciale infuser avec
une ambiance générale de répression on a
installé l'ensemble d'un système
potentiel donc le risque est
fondamentalement politique il ya un an
vous avez un argument qu un peu spéciaux
comme parce que vous nous dites vous
nous dites il ya un problème
démocratique et ensuite comme vous savez
très bien que tous les sondages sur ces
questions montrent qu'une immense
majorité de français est favorable aux
mesures de sécurité vous vous
décrédibilisez par avance le résultat de
ceux de ses études d'opinion en disant
qu' il ya risque démocratique mais les
le peuple n'est pas assez mûr pour
comprendre qu'un risque démocratique et
le peuple n'est pas assez mûrs pourquoi
parce qu'on lui cache les enjeux et que
en plus c'est que je résume de façon à
peine caractériel mais la caricature à
démarrer vous l'avez dit que j'avais
très peur
en plus et que en plus et je vais
caricaturer encore le peuple et
lobotomisés parce qu'on leur inculque eu
la peur moi je suis désolé je me balade
dans toute la france très régulièrement
puisque je dirige un think tank sur la
sécurité
je rencontre des gens qui sont pas tous
des malades de la société de sécurité
et je peux vous garantir pour rebondir
sous ce que vous avez peur c'est que
aujourd'hui alors certes moins qu'au
moyen âge mais beaucoup plus que depuis
que je suis adulte
j'ai 51 ans là ça fait on va dire 30 ans
que cela lui prend de 3 ans d'accord
c'est on est dans le pic des 40
dernières années de la montée de toute
forme de violence
je suis comme nous vous avez une chaleur
que l'on peut se passer qu'au effet déjà
passé de l'autre côté de la démocratie
moi je suis extrêmement inquiet ce n'est
pas le débat du jour sur ce qui nous
attend
je pense que les gens aussi et que tout
ce qu'on peut mettre en place pour
limiter l'impact de ce qui est en train
d'arriver à notre pays et plus largement
à notre continent
ce sont des choses que non seulement il
faut faire en faisant attention au cadre
juridique mais que les gens veulent
qu'on fasse
et pour finir sur l'argument des
pratiques si on faisait une sorte de
boîte à idées de consultation open bar
surtout ça vous seriez probablement si
deraîche de ce que le peuple demande
c'est à dire l'âge et rebondir sur
quelque chose que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure qui est affreusement vrai qui
est le côté inéluctable de ces
technologies qui viennent transformer la
société et pour boucler sur ce que vient
de dire est ce pas j'aurais juste voulu
souligner qu' il n'a aujourd'hui
politiquement deux forces en présence on
a les progressistes et les populismes si
ces catégories sont pas forcément très
précises on a vraiment ces deux forces
en présence
et force est de constater qu'on a des
progressistes totalement dépassé par le
progrès témoins ces lois qui centralise
là où la cybersécurité aurait voulu
décentraliser pour des raisons strictes
de sécurité pas d' usage les usages sur
elles mêmes mais on a des politiques des
législateurs qui font des choix
technologiques stupide
aux yeux des professionnels de la
technologie malgré tout ça avance et on
a de l'autre côté de l'atlantique un
groupe populiste composé de génie de
l'informatique peter t-il
son son poulain qui est mark zuckenberg
steve banos vice-présidente qu'un budget
les ti-cats ou robert mercer le
milliardaire fou mais qui aussi l'un des
pères fondateurs de l'intelligence
artificielle
tout ça c'est l'entourage technologique
de trump et tout ça a mis au point à
renouveler en profondeur les
technologies de propagande et nous a
donné comme génétique
c'est évident que l'europe va être à son
tour avalée par ça et il part il
apparaît absolument évident que le clan
des progressistes ne pourra pas résister
à ça donc on va arrêter de se mentir
cinq minutes de toute façon ça aussi
c'est inéluctable parce que ça c'est
justement porté par cette technologie
et on ne pourra pas y échapper donc il
serait peut être prudent et c'est un
message que je répète depuis maintenant
près de dix ans de commencer à se dire
que le système de gouvernance qui a géré
la france depuis
bon an mal an l'après-guerre et au mieux
l'arrivée de de gaulle et de la vème
république va connaître une fois très
rapide très très rapide parce que
justement il n'est pas apte à se saisir
de la chose technologique et il suffit
d'aller voir à l'assemblée nationale
pour son crs en gros mc et en face on a
des gens qui sont extrêmement sachant
très très très compétents et qu'ils
savent parfaitement s'entourer
les jeux sont faits et donc demain nous
aurons une autre forme de régime
politique
on verra bien ce que ça donnera qui se
saisira de l'arsenal technologie est là
dessus force est de constater que non le
contrôle législatif de la surveillance
c'est du pipeau qu'on a une micro
commission qui n'a pas la moindre
capacité technique en son sein pour
aller audits et des algorithmes ce qui
laisse pantois n'importe quelle
spécialité technologie et que si demain
je carrière et capture dans des
proportions démesurées mais si demain
adolf hitler venait à être élu en france
il aurait plein pouvoir pour transformer
de façon radicale le système de
gouvernance qu'on a sans se faire passer
un seul texte de loi dont on en est là
on pourra pas revenir en arrière un jeu
plaident même pas sa fille il ya l'état
de droit au niveau européen qui peut
l'état de droit le l'europe nous a dit à
plusieurs reprises que la fourberie ça
suffisait de tout et les deux rois
aujourd'hui c'est l'europe s'est dit non
non non non non non c'est en veille
pas du tout ça reste nationale
typiquement l'europe des avis contraires
à de multiples reprises sur les
différentes technologies de surveillance
qu'on a mis en place en france l'état
français n'en a pas tenu compte
oui oui je sais bien je connais les
droits aujourd'hui est incarnée par par
là dessus pas nationalité qui est
l'europe à bastille l'arc un départ sera
dévoilée à lui on est il nous reste
quelques minutes il n'y a pas de
problème en général quand on parle de
sécurité qu'on invoque la sécurité on
sait très bien ce que ça veut dire c'est
qu'au nom de la sécurité on est prêt à
renier ou à réduire drastiquement nous
liberté et est généralement quand on
évoque la peur la terreur et comme on
l'a vu beaucoup fait ces dernières
années
c'est pour préparer la population à ce
qu'un gouvernement autoritaire puissent
quand même ce serait pas si mal que ça
mesdames n aurait pas d'accord avec
cette vision mais dans quoi vous avez
peur qu'on vous baladez vous avez peur
moi j'ai jamais peur j'ai moins peur des
terroristes est un cas spécial ne le
prenez pas exemple sur moi bravant les
terroristes sortie des films en même
temps parce que moi c'est normal que je
me balade en ville ou ou n'importe où
ailleurs dans des quartiers
je n'ai pas peur particulièrement même
si je voulais me faire le parcours en
dit vous avez pas peur des délinquants
vous n'êtes pas patiné dans la rue match
de lorient dans un attentat donc sinon
c'est pas ce que je dis c'est un endroit
où vous allez jamais vous balader jamais
oui mais quand vous prenez ça paraissait
jusqu'à vous prenez arrive
est ce que disait monsieur très
justement moi je fais une soixantaine de
villes par an à travers mes opérations
dans les quartiers on a les quartiers
effectivement qui sont touchés par les
problèmes de délinquance de criminologie
conte de trafic de stups etc les gens
sont à l'agonie au niveau sécuritaire il
nous faut des policiers il nous faut des
policiers municipaux il nous faut des
caméras etc
moi j'entends que ça et je me balade
dans juste soixante villes en france
je vais pas dans les endroits les plus
simples évidemment je me balade pas sur
les champs elysées je suis dans les
quartiers que ce soit au tertre et que
ce soit se rend au botox que jouent les
dirigeants sont terrorisés jeu les
cobayes doigt que d'insécurité je
condamne pas ces gens là ils ne vivent
pas dans les mêmes quartiers et moi et
je peux tout est m on avait dit juste
que quand on a peur on est plus
facilement en anglais à ce gran torino
le disco
rick est pas un gouvernement autoritaire
de débats houleux débats sion si on fait
deux secondes de philosophie moi je
conteste absolument l'opposition entre
les deux pourquoi parce que là la
sécurité c'est le choc pour exercer des
libertés c'est que si on vous donne
toutes les libertés que vous voulez mais
sauf que vous n'avez pas les bases de la
sécurité pour les exercer si on vous dit
par exemple on a toujours un exemple
caricatural pardon c'est le propre des
exemples à partir de demain c'est vrai
on supprime tous les contrôles pour
prendre l'avion voulait réalise allait
prendre la navette air france vous
arrivés dix minutes avant de partir les
90 premiers arrivés monde dans l'avion
sans contrôle comme ça avec le gros
manteaux les bagages je vous garantis
que plus personne ne montera dans
l'avion la mesure sera vide
et pourtant vous avez liberté totale de
le prône donc dur à bois et vous aurez
une relation aurait pas de place pour
vos jambes
c'est un vrai sujet là ou là où le sujet
est complexe et je le reconnais bien
volontiers
c'est que effectivement il ya la
tentation qui peut être une tentation
qui est loin de résident et simple sur
les seuls états on le disait tout à
l'heure de prendre le contrôle d'un
certain nombre de choses et la dernière
chose que je veux dire et là c'est aussi
une manière de jeter un pont avec avec
nos amis en face qui qui qui dit
beaucoup de choses est également censé
c'est que moi ce qui me fait peur et je
n'ai même plus loin que vous alors ça va
vous surprendre
c'est pas simplement ce que vous dites
parce que ce que je suis conscient que
c'est un problème c'est le fait que nos
sociétés sont de plus en plus des
sociétés totalement assisté par la
technologie et que nos petits enfants
déjà nos enfants et nos petits enfants
seront tout à fait incapable d'être
autonome sur des actes de la vie
courante qui pourtant sont des actes de
base de l'activité humaine et je hais et
dans ce contexte si jamais un jour
quelle que soit l'origine il y avait une
rupture technologique
alors ce serait une catastrophe comme
l'humanité nom n'a jamais connu fabrice
epelboin il y aura une rupture
technologique c'est après visionnement
inéluctable et c'est pour ça que la
construction sociale price aux slovènes
qui ont 10 à vous de toute façon n'est
pas durable il va y avoir des ruptures
et valeur à des ruptures fondamentales
et la première rupture elle sera non
seulement politique parce que
effectivement le camp qu'affrontent les
progressistes aujourd'hui est infiniment
plus sachant et vous trouvez aussi dans
la sociologie d'internet 1
les ceux qui sont étiquetés fachos
aujourd'hui sur internet
concrètement ils sont là qu'une
génération alors que les autres sont là
depuis quelques années donc forcément il
ya une différentiel dans l'art et la
manière d'argumenter en politique de
convaincre l'autre est de faire de la
politique qui est phénoménal
absents ont fait de même on ne pourra
pas résister à ça il faut être bien
conscient
la seule question c'est 2022 au plus
tard mais de plus en plus tout le monde
se dit qu'effectivement ça va être 2022
et ça jouera évidemment sur internet
tout comme les précédentes élections
américaines s'est joué intégralement sur
internet ces technologies sont très au
point et la france a pris un retard qui
n'est pas rattrapable la france
considérait encore ces technologies là
comme de l'or de la tiru du complot il
ya quelques années les anglais le
département de la défense anglaise a
développé des technologies tic en plus
j'ai eu ni cas en 2015
donc c'est vous dire l'allèle l'écart
spectaculaire qu'il ya entre la france
et les nations qui maîtrise ses
technologies là n'est pas de taille à
lutter par ailleurs on va aussi avoir
droit à une multitude d'effets de bord
et les effets de bord avec la
technologie sont souvent inattendues je
vous en citer deux le premier c'est
cette idée d'une reconnaissance faciale
généralisée et d'un permis à points
comme en chine
en pratique on l'a déjà on avons tous un
permis de conduire et si on commet une
infraction sur la route on est
sanctionné au bout d'un moment nous
n'avons plus droit nous déplacer ce qui
nous importe peu pour nous autres
parisiens mais dans des zones de
campagne c'est ne plus avoir son permis
de conduire c'est vraiment une
interdiction d'un droit fondamental à se
déplacer et on vit depuis déjà plus
d'une décennie dans ce système de
surveillance généralisée sur le réseau
autorités qui nous sanctionne si jamais
monté il ya peu de temps
ça ne vous aura pas échappé on a un peu
resserré la vis on est passé de 90 km
heure à 80 km/heure et on a constaté un
léger effet de bord qui s'est manifestée
par un phénomène d'émeutes généralisées
d'un pays on aura ce genre d'effets de
bord avec la vidéosurveillance ils sont
très difficiles à anticiper
on aura désormais des effets de bord
avec par exemple la loi qui a été votée
aujourd'hui compound censée lutter
contre la haine
très concrètement cette loi ne peut pas
être appliquée par des algorithmes dieu
merci et on est très très loin des rois
d'algoé qui font de la modération vont
être appliquées par va dire des switchs
de modération qui sont localisés dans
des pays distant à bas coût en terme de
main d'oeuvre et qui ont également une
culture très distant de la nôtre quelque
chose qui serait considéré comme de la
haine en france ne le serai pas là bas
et réciproquement
on a eu aujourd'hui à hashtag qui a fait
trading topi toute la journée sur des
réactions un peu épidermique entre des
critiques de la religion et des
pratiquants de cette religion qui se
sont affrontés sur les réseaux sociaux
je vous laisse imaginer ce qu aurait été
cet épisode syllabes été modérée à
casablanca
parce que c'est ça à quoi donc l on va
faire face et ses multiples effets de
bord et ils seront d'autant plus
multiples qu'on a encore une fois un
législateur qui ne comprend même pas la
technologie de base qui l'essentiel est
différent et en même temps dernière
phrase tous les deux ans j'utilise pour
revenir aux villes et à la sécurité dans
les villes c'est inéluctable
d'insécurité la technologie à la
sécurité un exemple à sevran tout
simplement pour donner parce que je
voulais stéphane gatignon qui était un
anti caméra anti police municipale etc
vous allez voir le maire actuel il
pleure allemand les gens demandent des
incivilités comment on fait comment
créer mettre en place des caméras etc
il a perdu dix ans et c'est une
catastrophe à ce rang après j'aimerais
attirer mon sens est pragmatique
quels sont les comportements individuels
tout ça s'inscrit dans un cadre de
recherche européen qu'il est en place
depuis dix ans qui s'appelle indect et
je vous invite à regarder sur internet
ce qui indexe dont le but est de
rassembler tous les systèmes de
vidéosurveillance de les faire passer
dans une moulinette algorithmique qui va
être en mesure de prédire la foule est
là on est très clairement sur des
technologies dont le but et l'ordre
social absolument pas démocratie l'ordre
social du contrat social intériorisé non
juste sur la sécurité évidemment je suis
d'accord et tout à l'heure je l'évoquais
le contrat social liberté sécurité
évidemment le vrai sujet c'était pas la
sécurité le vrai sujet c'est est ce
qu'on est prêt à renier à notre vie
privée et à certains droits fondamentaux
pour cette sécurité où cet ultra
sécurité et l'ama tout dernièrement sur
l'intrication que vous avez essayé
d'évoquer à quelques reprises entre
privé et public et en effet on a
beaucoup parlé des tas de police est en
effet les grandes entreprises
aujourd'hui c'est des marchés publics
privés qui sont énormes qui sont de
l'ordre
liards de dollars en fête est donc en
effet il ya un énorme sujet et qui
génèrent des transferts de souveraineté
notamment sur des fonctions régaliennes
de sécurité bercy tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]